we've got ourselves one hell of a
conversation that seems just dropped
right before the music ended so I'm kind
of excited
Christopher Sims how are you I got
button swag yes that's what I do
wow man I don't know what color that
shirt is looks like lavender but it
makes those blue eyes pop it is lavender
I know I need to I want to start wearing
this shirt some the show more I mean
this is what I do this is what I am Josh
vendrick in his comfortable gray sweater
that here is I'm here but don't notice
me too much it's pretty much a new
sweater though this is j.crew summer
sale oh okay yeah hello and I am here in
the All Blacks head-to-toe black which
is the official outfit of New York if
you live in New York long enough
eventually all of your clothes just
become black that's what it's easy
I'm all for all black wait can we have
the conversation that we just started
because I want to hear the answer I have
a run down in front I would like to
tease things okay go ahead holy crap end
of the show really fun conversation with
Stefon Diggs and I would honestly tell
you guys to go check out the youtube go
to bleacher report Sims and Lefko and if
you're if you're watching this stay
tuned to the end if you're listening to
this go check it out because Stefon
Diggs was in stitches yeah I mean he was
laughing the whole time he's a guy that
we've interviewed a lot he was blown
away at the Super Bowl that you don't
have Instagram right he was teaching me
how to do the perfect Milly rock wears
the same t-shirt every time we say I'm
Old Spice brought to you by Old Spice
Foam spray but honestly was a really fun
conversation a little bit about football
is Adam feeling over eight underrated
because of you know he's Adam feeling he
had a culture will divide discussion
Kirk Cousins why do people disrespect
them but that was really good
conversation we have Phil Simms coming
up we're gonna dive into Sims as
notebook Chris Simms is notebook a few
more games to get through some big news
but the conversation that you want to
get into is I want to make Quinton
Nelson the official offensive lineman of
the Sims and Lefko podcast and I feel
like we've kind of been doing that for a
while yeah um I think he should be I
mean we have a history together at Notre
Dame I mean it just like it should be
he likes you you're you're hiding him we
did an Old Spice thing you can't like
you text people all the time and I never
accuse you of being a stalker and then
just because I text people I'm not a
stalker
I want to do the left go DM Power
Rankings where we rank all the people
that he DM oh yeah the good thing is is
when you're DMing with Quinton Nelson I
don't have to defend him right because I
already know he's amazing right really
quick before we have this discussion
where is quit Nelson right now in terms
of offensive lime in the NFL like easy
Rd at top five offensive linemen without
a doubt yes and how rare is that for a
guy that's played ten games yeah it's
like happens once every five or six
years maybe less than that Zac Martin's
the last guy to do that you win he was
in the draft you called him a
generational interior offensive lineman
has he even maybe exceeded your
expectations yes he has yes I mean I
just don't know you know I knew he would
be good I just didn't know if he'd come
in and dominate right away sometimes you
just got to kind of get a feel for the
league certain matchups you're learning
a new offense doing all these things but
yes I would say he is the best guard in
football already and yes over Zac my I
would if you gave me just from what a
great film this year yeah I'd probably
go Nelson Pete Martin as my three guards
Oh semele because he's usually yeah
Assembly's been banged up a little bit
this year so it's its own else's already
number one yeah I would say him and
Peter dueling it out I mean yeah I mean
from what I just saw and I know we're
gonna get into it with Pete just every
game he's the same way it's a road
grader would you have taken quit Nelson
I'm gonna go through the top six picks
in the draft okay would you have taken
him over Baker no okay would you have
taken him over say Kwan no would you
have taken him over Sam darn 'old hmm oh
that's certainly 50/50 would you have
taken him over Denzel Ward
mmm probably at that times yeah I would
now in them you think about it they came
back in the early second round and they
took Austin Corbett who hasn't played
this right and I you know and I would
argue and I think the would proven never
just as good even in the first round
like the Browns could have traded down
or traded up to get back in the first
trying to get the Jair Alexander's of
the Mike Hughes or those other guys
Denver Broncos that's a tough one
rattling shut or quit Nelson yeah Chubb
has certainly come on big-time mm
probably just because of the pass
rushing position I probably still go a
job but we we said this about quick
Nelson before the draft when you have a
guy that you know is transcendent yeah
it's at a position that's maybe not the
most important right stuff yeah
now speaking of pass rushers yes josh
asked you right beforehand right Aaron
Donald versus Quintin Nelson yeah who
would win in that battle yeah I mean all
right so I and where I was leaving off
that conversation I mean Aaron Donald's
awesome right we all know that I'm not
sitting here trying to even didn't
dispel that myth
he is the best defensive player in
football but he's not like perfect every
player has kryptonite okay nobody has
been perfect I mean nobody and I mean
again you've seen their run defense
lately I mean it's not perfect all the
time because he's a speed guy they shoot
gaps they try to create chaos all those
things if him and Quintin Nelson lined
up you know 50 times in front of each
other throughout a full game um I think
Quentin Nelson would win the majority of
the run game run game design plays yes
one on one he to lose a few here and
there because of just the speed and
quickness like if Nelson has one
weakness so far it would be just some of
those quick guys at times like Malik
Jackson I think got him once or twice
last week there was a game earlier this
year but he kind of got beat off the
line and someone got the sack yeah where
they went on this four-game line of no
side I would say that's his only little
weakness and we'll work on that yeah he
will work on that you can work on that
you know that's short area quickness
that's just getting used to freaky guys
that you really you don't see in college
football until you get to the NFL but
then we get to the pass game and you
know again Nelson I'm not if they drop
back 40 times I mean Aaron Donald's not
gonna get 20 sacks that's not even
realistic in the world of football but
he would certainly have his moments of
disruption I mean that's where he makes
his money but I do think Nelson would
hold his own almost as good as like an
Andrus peat like I would say Andrus peat
can be a slight edge better as a pass
protecting guard then maybe Quentin
Nelson like Andrus peat gave game Aaron
Donald all he can handle
pass game have you seen so when I
watched some of the questions you did
and I wanna do some follow-up yeah I was
watching some of the Jaguars highlights
and for the first time I'm seeing Marcel
Darius on his back yeah I'm seeing Malik
Jackson on his back right I saw coleus
Campbell on his back right and you
really never see that and then on them
is quit Nelson like surfing on them
being like right I have you on the
ground right the dirt do you have you
seen Aaron down on his back at all this
year
oh not on his back like the ones you're
talking about there's thirst plays where
he gets driven back and somebody drives
into the ground but it's not like BAM I
got pancaked it's like oh let me turn
sideways to stop he's racing to a point
and now that crumbled down he's crumbled
down a little bit but he's not like
Nelson just jumping on and like I I
begged you now I'm gonna drive you six
inches deeper into the ground
Donald will a hundred percent beat
Nelson on a few plays yeah just Karin
yeah that's how good he is right will
would Nelson put him on his back hmm
a player too I mean probably not but I
do think he could drive him back in
Sicily you know Aaron Donald's
freakishly strong so he has the perfect
physique yeah for that position
he does I mean he can just you know he's
just got a naturally gigantic man like
Aaron Donald's is probably a guy that
when he stops playing football he's
thick and dense he'll be you know six
foot or six one 275 or 270 but he's such
a workout warrior that he's 285 or 290
with just extra 15 or 20 pounds of
muscle that's definitely one of the the
the line matchups that I'd love to see
yeah yeah that would just be so fun it
would be a good one I'm realizing as I'm
talking right now you put out that clip
so four years ago guys we started the
Sims and left kopaka
this week which is crazy yeah I got a
time hop on my facebook that was like I
got a podcast and it was like me with a
lot more hair a time hop so on Facebook
right this is a great when you post
things Facebook will be like seven years
ago today you posted and it's like mom I
hate you you never make my bed and I'm
like oh and so I for some reason went on
Facebook I don't go often and I saw that
and Joshua's like
I can go and find our first podcast I
think the most jarring thing about you
posting that clip is my voice your voice
like it's really weird I'm going to play
it kinda someone even commented they're
like oh man you used to have a radio
voice good for you getting rid of it
because I guess back then I was like
Adam here with Chris Sam's Chris how are
you today yeah you're still stuck in
that model role like I say I'm Yuka see
you do sound a little bit now there's
your gonna say something right you're
gonna say something right now that has
stayed true for four years this part
right here is 45 seconds of the podcast
a complaint about film watch that's not
understanding technology right I think
we've stayed true yeah
back when we were holding microphones oh
my god and then later in that clip I go
and I'm drinking a beer right now
that music was like I Dream of Jeannie
yes it's not even I drew that's porn
music I mean I don't even know what that
is we could bring it back if you want
not rid of the rod Sandro no we would
never do that never do that
the big news yesterday before we get
into your film the biggest game of the
season
Chiefs Rams is now being moved from
Mexico City to LA after it has been
discovered that that field looked like
the surface of Mars it looked as though
they were like we have an idea for a
field a deconstructed field a little bit
of dirt a little bit of grass you Ron
you may trip you never know the video
that I posted yesterday that
you saw that was the worst looking field
I've ever seen and what you discovered
was the concert was a month ago
yeah the concert was not Saturday that's
what I thought all along when this first
came out I was like man they had a
concert this week that's really stupid
yes and then my thoughts shifted to wait
the concert was a month ago
man the NFL is really stupid I mean
again there's the NFL what were they
doing saving the plane flied down for
nobody to go check the field and they
were gonna check at the week of the game
I mean there's the other felt cutting
corners you know we don't have anybody
there to look at the ball pressure we
don't have the right officials in the
booth to do this like hundreds of
thousands of dollars they're worried
about when they make billions a year now
that I think about it in one of the
previews the Monday Night Football crew
they showed a shot inside Mexico City's
I think it's stadium a stack right and
it was people sodding the field yes like
now that I think about that shot they're
like they're like mowing the grass they
were going to salvage this and they
wanted to play the game there it would
have been remember that Eagles Ravens
pregame we're like there was like holes
in the field they're like we're not
gonna play well that's what happened
just I know this this the reason the
league cancelled it was finally when
they got that word that players might
not play in the game and that's when
they finally said ok we have to cancel
it now they were gonna try to make this
happen they we're gonna go I'll [ __ ] you
guys get out there in the sod it's been
there for four days it's great think
about the money that's being lost with
this yeah think about all of the
promotions and all of the things that
the NFL probably set up down there this
has probably been months and months of
planning think about the money that ESPN
is spending yeah right they probably
outfitted that entire stadium with
camera crews they probably sent down
tons of things the staffing they've
hired that's all cancelled with a few
days notice I wonder how that works
there's like the NFL pay is hand back
for that charge that they screw they
screw it up well their relationships
been fantastic so yeah sure that'll be
easy but I would also say that the
people that I feel the worst for yeah
are the people like my dad who before
the year go hey we go to one away game
every year alright which one are we
gonna go tonight the people that said
let's go to Mexico on Wednesday we'll
have the whole week the whole weekend
and then Monday night we can go to the
game it's gonna be super great I feel
bad for all those people that
was their trip and as the seasons going
along they're going it's gonna be nine
and one nine in one way we bought these
great and now their whole trip is done
do they get trip do they get free
tickets to the game I mean that they've
already purchased and they get to go to
LA now I mean it's not a bad consolation
prize right I don't know it is this week
with all the smoke in the air but then I
know like the LA Rams are giving away
all these tickets to people that
suffered on this care and I go one
that's great - awesome left go PR - go
we can't get enough Rams fans and we're
really afraid that cheese fans are gonna
come in and take over our stadium so
let's give out local tickets yeah not
saying your charity is awarded right
just saying left go PR a win-win that's
another benefit of yeah without a doubt
but this whole situation so you take
this as what the heck was the NFL doing
I take the NFL as what the heck are they
doing on a weekly basis with the fields
across the league again you guys know it
to me it's like mind blowing Monday
Night Football
exactly right I mean say Quan Barkley
had to come out of the game and put
different cleats on here to put
three-quarter-inch spikes on to go play
because people were slipping all over
the field what was wrong with the field
they do the same thing I don't know we
need to look up when's the last concert
they have when they have away games they
have concert that week and then they put
down these mats and everybody walks on
it and that makes the facade softer and
everything like that you know the NFL
talks about wasting millions and I go
you waste millions on paying guys every
year who get hurt on bad playing
services that is an issue within this
sport you know and I just don't
understand that part of it you know I
don't understand you know why college
and high school players playing a better
quality field than grown men who are
being paid millions of dollars it makes
no sense to me I used to drive me crazy
in Tampa when I would play a game in
Tampa we had the best field in cotton
football until the college season
started and then South Florida would
play the night before and then here we
come out and we're planning on dirt that
spray-painted green so it looked good on
TV exactly and it's just it's BS and
just repainted the dirt spray-painted it
Wow
yeah I I will say though I'm a little
bit excited that the game was moved
because it was really upsetting me that
the game of the year was being played in
another
country and a super high elevation that
would have tired out the players right
that and also that I had to listen to
the Monday Night Football crew yeah I
was I was all of the aspects of watching
that game I won it on I really want the
game in Dallas I really want the game in
Jacksonville I really want the game in a
neutral site because that's how good
this matchup is yeah but I'm happy that
it's an LA yeah because why were the
Rams losing this home game you're trying
to convince people in Mexico to become
NFL fans because you're behind all the
other sports in terms of international
flavor I get it you want to expand your
brand but it's at the like it was gonna
I thought it was gonna be like a twenty
three to twenty game because of the
altitude and that we're in another
country and I'm glad now that it's at a
normal place where the game will be fun
so now we're the Rams a disadvantage
though why would the Rams because they
traveled to Colorado to get used to the
altitude and now they're in Colorado and
now they're gonna fly back home which is
weird too I mean it's it's all weird
yeah but at least throw it home yeah I
know I'm just it's just still we were
there any concerts and studio a studio
has to have I have not I have not found
a Levi's Stadium schedule yet I'm still
gonna watch the game on espn2 this
Monday I've decided what do you mean
they show it on the offense to ESPN
Deportes it's the Spanish speaking
broadcast of Monday night function we
make that a thing for the podcast that
we only watch Monday Night Football on
ESPN Deportes because the question that
I asked myself and I know that
everyone's been very hard on this
broadcasting group and I know that you
think that I harp on it but every time I
watch it really pains me and I really
can't do it anymore
what am I missing if I don't watch the
that broadcast yeah I don't think I'm
missing anything I get you unless I miss
my favorite takes that Eli's not a
hall-of-famer which I know you kind of
agree with I definitely agree with that
I mean that's to me is you know I just
the two Super Bowl things Hall of Fame
Hall of Fame why isn't Jim Plunkett in
then I just want to say that you know
Eli Manning he's a danger if he goes to
the Hall of Fame he's in danger of
becoming a below 500 quarterback in his
career does that speak to Hall of Fame
absolutely not so you know I'm just
again he's not even he's not even the
best quarterback in his own draft class
he's third I don't care if Philip Rivers
never wins a Super Bowl his career is
better than Eli Manning it's not being a
hater I'm just trying to keep it real
there Eli Manning's
rear record is 113 and 110 right so
really I could see the Giants losing
more games down the stretch than winning
and where he could end this year with a
career losing record right and where
people lose context of that and go well
so you kind of agree with booger I I do
I think it's very borderline I mean
again it's just the rings discussion
because I know Michael Strahan and
Justin Tuck and all those guys they
weren't good in the game I mean he'll I
really blew the doors off in that game
1714 I mean to me that's where it just
it gets annoying that conversation all
the time
rings rings rings rings well you know
why the Giants had to fight so hard and
those those two playoff runs because Eli
was below average or average all year
long and they ended up nine and seven
when in reality the team was like a 12
and 4 team I mean that's where like
context matters and that's like I feel
like my new phrase lately I'm context
matters yes it's my catchphrase yeah my
my thing with Eli back to my can you
tell the story the NFL without Eli right
I don't know if you can no you can't
because of the 17 and OH Patriots and
being that and he's an NFL legend you
know I'm not gonna sit here and stamp
the Hall of Fame career on him he's
having his best quarterback rating year
this year I have to question right one
do you think the Giants won Eli to be
their starting quarterback next season
no I don't think so I don't know that
either just a statement I don't think so
no my follow up what can they be
watching to really think that yes it's
gonna turn it around dude I don't know
what anyone's watching so I don't assume
anything you're right my other question
though is if Eli ends the year right
with a career record of a below 500 yeah
do you think it's gonna make him want to
come back next year no I don't so you
don't think he'll be like man I would
like to go 90s they don't bother him but
I don't think it's going to dictate him
coming back to play you know I'd have to
question Eli along this process - I
gotta go - I would I would go to Eli
going what are what are you watching
well are you're watching yourself on
film every week do you really think your
starting quarterback material and I know
I know I sound insensitive here but I'm
just trying to
evaluate the situation Eli's great like
I said he's a legend motor line
hall-of-famer I like seeing the come the
the the last drive he sure was mainly
because of to pass interference but I
got it yeah I mean there's been a lot of
great moments he's clutch he's
unflappable those are things that he
certainly has been I give him credit for
that
I just not gonna stand Paula Fame on it
though just just because it's two rings
if you didn't watch Monday Night
Football and go wow even though
everybody knows he's trying to throw to
Odell and Odell can still get open by
such a large gap that even Eli could
make the throw right and he's the guy
that makes the system work yeah I don't
know what to tell you yeah I don't know
either I mean you know well yeah I mean
he missed you know that should have been
a touchdown but the one he'd go route
that he under throws and I think he
became pass interference or tool yeah so
yeah I get you I know we're at a point
though where I think we're kind of fed
up talking about it and we're not we're
not trying to harp it's just you know
it's the number one media market in the
NFL with two of the best weapons that
are in the enough I don't get on this
booger McFarland subject Mexico okay
let's dive in the film notebook Falcons
Browns yeah and my big question before
this was the Browns offense and Freddie
kitchens right baby lead me through it
cuz it's in my phone so I got it yeah
Baker Mayfield has his stats the last
two games his quarterback ratings been
amazing I think it's like five
touchdowns one interception Nick Chubb
he's been going off they've had a good
offensive line the entire year just
overarching question is it Freddie
kitchens what is he doing that that
makes you go wow Cleveland's offense
last two weeks really been functioning
high I think you know sometimes it goes
back to basics that you and I talk about
a lot on this podcast he's playing
through his strength and maybe the
strength and the overall strength of the
whole Cleveland Browns football team is
there oh line I mean they got you know
JC Treader at center Joel Antonio at
guards eichler at the other guard I mean
they have a very good Oh line and then
of course now they have Nick Chubb who's
a special runner and I think that's what
has changed more than anything they've
kind of gotten back to like Oh
old-school Pittsburgh football we're
from the 13 12 and 13 personnel to
Charles Betty's up your ass here I go
yeah oh you're gonna play one-on-one
outside our quarterbacks got a strong
arm he can throw outs and comebacks all
game and throw them on the money and
that to me is a special thing too that
goes overlooked like you know that you
love their tight ends for all those
there that's very good exactly right and
Baker is the type of quarterback who you
know in the game the thing that jumped
out to me skinny posts okay skinny posts
are like slant routes but their post
routes where the quarterback takes five
steps and he doesn't take a hitched up
he hits that fifth step and just lets it
loose not a lot of quarterbacks feel
comfortable throwing that throughout and
he does that because of the flow because
you don't know what's gonna be happening
yes you can it's kind of more of a I got
a see the window I got a match up my
feet with it and then I gotta throw the
Hallett sir in there to get this ball in
and he has a howitzer so he does that
and he could throw deep comebacks and
deep outs which a lot of quarterbacks
are reluctant to throw because they're
not easy throws they have to be pinpoint
and if you do error or throw a bad throw
it usually becomes a pick in those kind
of plays so I think that's the big thing
more than anything they're playing
through their strengths of their team
first and that's giving them an
advantage to go okay we're gonna run the
ball and now okay we're two big plays
come from we watch it all the time the
biggest plays of the week for the Rams
the Saints and the New England Patriots
is always awful play-action pass yes and
they do that so that is one of the
things they got going for that I was
gonna say it's not often when you say
the Browns are like the Pats and Saints
but the philosophy has been when we when
we bring everybody in right it's a power
formation we're throwing it yeah when we
spread you out
we're running exactly they do a little
bit of that Cleveland they really do and
it sounds like you believe that a lot of
kitchens is Bruce Arians Katharine and
this feels like a Bruce Arians offense
to you it's like an old-school Bruce
Arians which is where kitchens came
exactly right that's what it was it's
Bruce Arians and he's Pittsburgh guide
to Bruce Arians that's the kind of thing
he he has always done whether it was the
Colts even they had that element of
their offense to with with Peyton
Manning getting in 12 personnel
play-action passes oh you're gonna try
to stop Edgerrin run
Edgerrin James runs okay well peyton
manning's got a strong arm he'll throw
the 20 yard comeback to Marvin Harrison
and he'll be open and they'll throw it
on the screws every time so yeah that's
kind of their philosophy there and
Freddie kitchens yes it's not about
spreading it out dink and dunk it's more
about smashmouth we got a few dink and
dunk plays here great screen play down
the red zone to Chubb right then went
for the touchdown but more or not
they're looking for explosive plays or
chunk plays in the past you're telling
me that Todd Haley gets fired and then
Freddie kitchens just walks in the next
week and says this is the offense we're
doing now guys it's I've been sitting on
this the whole season right but the
offense is there but what he goes is
this part of our offense that we've been
neglecting we're gonna make it more of
our center point why didn't he just tell
that to Todd Haley
well because it's hard to do it's this
is the army remember it's army you don't
know said we're going for wives and
shotgun and I also think offensive
coordinators when they get quarterbacks
like a Baker Mayfield or anything like
that they fall into the trap of I want
to put up good stats I'm a quarterback
whisperer because you know what the
quarterback whisperer but good stats is
gonna do get me another head coaching
yeah and I think too much sometimes
Oasys get in love with that and they
forget like man if I just win the game
and we look good on offense I'll be the
quarterback whisperer - this is the
stuff I just hate hearing well one of my
philosophies has always been you learn
more from a bad boss
than you do from a good boss when you're
play when you're a quarterback coach
under Josh McDaniels you're not even
gonna learn that much stuff because you
go man when Josh calls that play it
always works and you don't learn the
meaning behind it but when you're
Freddie kitchens and you're behind Hugh
Jackson and Todd Haley and you're
sitting there going - going
why is he neglecting this it enlightens
you think about your own workplace if
you have a bad boss when you you can
look at him and go well when I'm a boss
I'm not gonna do this I'm not gonna do
this I'm not gonna do this but when you
have a good boss you take all the things
they do for granted yeah and I think
when you get there you go I can fix this
because I know exactly what they've been
doing wrong right I I was lucky enough
early on in my career I had a lot of bad
bosses sure I'd rather have bad bosses
earlier than bad bosses late that's
for sure because then when you have a
good boss you go damn I appreciate ya
yeah no doubt
Falcons offense screwed up a lot yeah
that was your biggest issue with them
well I mean just the one of those is a
totally Devon Drake Campbell quote where
he's like we just we thought they were
the Browns no dad I sent you these notes
before that but yeah they're just there
they're there from the get-go one team
was obviously the more hungry physical
team on film I mean within the first
Drive you just said damn the Browns came
to play and the Falcons thought they
could just show up and make it happen
because it's the Browns and yes I mean
hey whether it was miss throws in a few
situations by Matt Brian you know stupid
play calling on third and one from the
one-inch line and not running a
quarterback sneak which you did the play
before and they jumped offsides and you
got half the distance and you're gonna
have a touchdown but then you decided
not to do it I don't know why I don't
know why I don't know why you know Alex
Mack throw out snapping the ball over
Matt Ryan's head and another time when
they're in field goal position Mohamed
Sanu being four yards away from a first
down and reaching for it like he might
get it and then he fumbled Oh shocker so
how do you see hunger on film you can
just tell with like who's hitting for
one who's getting up after the hitting
and going we just hate you know we
coming back again you know you could see
the emotion through the film just guys
talking to each other and high up
definitely yes because as they make the
tackle the closer it zooms in a little
too but you could see the guys you know
their heads jar in and you know like
they're talking to the guy on the ground
one team was doing that and the other
team was not hmm yeah I like that
question how do you see hunger alright
Cardinals chiefs yeah a game that I got
right you got it wrong okay so this has
been something though about the
Cardinals that I feel like the Cardinals
and the bills are in a very similar
situation good from perspective very
good early on the bills got shellacked
by the Ravens and we wrote them off
immediately right the Cardinals got
smacked I think 34 to nothing by the
Rams I we wrote them off immediately
exactly Byron Leftwich has come in David
Johnson's getting the ball more in the
passing game the offense is clicking but
I would argue throughout all of the
season the bills and Cardinals defenses
their game plans had
been pretty spot-on yes they have like
I'm telling you I really think if you go
back and look at that first game of the
year when Washington beat Arizona like
twenty four to eight yeah if you look at
that second half of the game right
Arizona was all over Washington I
couldn't do anything right so this game
I'm watching because I'm going I'm very
curious
well the Chiefs can't cover the sixteen
and a half the Cardinals were getting
pressure on Patrick mahomes really the
entire game sacked five times it was the
first time where I went
mahomes getting sacked in the red zone
it's just wild right I look at your
notes yeah Chandler Jones
Rodney Gunter blowing it up but you
wrote man the coaches were all over the
Chiefs stuff right the cheese are just
too fast for this team but are you
impressed with Steve Wilkes defense
right now without a doubt and I'm glad
you can kind of lumped it with McDermott
because that's what this boy they're
both Carolina Panthers right that's the
sound defense sound defense and it's not
always man-to-man as a little sprinkle
right then don't break everybody's eyes
on the quarterback on the ball we rally
we make the tackle when they get in
certain formations these are two coaches
that are very good at teaching their
back seven route reading hey they're in
trips when the number one receiver does
this the number two receiver does that
so now they're in the zone okay they're
in a zone but they're also like oh gosh
- went vertical that means ones coming
underneath and then they're all over it
and that zone collapses in a hurry and
you go Dave how'd they get all that's
that's coaching right there and that's
really what it looked like more than
anything you know early on they caught
him by surprise
because of what you said I mean you can
prepare for Kansas City all you want and
then you see Tyree but then the first
time you see the homes and Tyree kilt
throw the ball you go holy [ __ ] I wasn't
ready for that they told me all week to
get back and I didn't get back fast
enough yeah because they let up that
touchdown and I'm sure everybody was
like here goes the Chiefs but as soon as
that touchdown was over right it was a
game it was a game I mean the Cardinals
had a chance to win this game up until
Justin Houston intercepted the screen
pass right the Cardinals were driving
down to take the lead right did that
scare you about the Chiefs well no I
mean no because again
don't underestimate good coaches and and
you're gonna say Steve Wilkes is a good
coach I on the defensive side of the
ball
certainly certainly I mean what he did
to Shanahan 49ers offense a few weeks
ago yeah what he's don't do it both
times actually they beat him twice yes
but especially the last one in Arizona
points yeah I mean yes he is a really
good sound defensive coach and I'd also
like to remind everybody too this is not
a finished product you know this is a
team that's going to mow a three-four
scheme and now making a transition to a
totally different 4-3 scheme right and
you got to let the players match up with
that first two but he's getting it there
and I do like the look and Chandler
Jones is popping every week what
Chandler Jones is probably the most
underrated defensive player in the sport
right now I mean he is without question
in the conversation top-ten defensive
players in NFL every time you turn on
the force I mean he is an absolute force
yes I mean he's unbelievable and yet he
causes a lot of havoc they got Hassan
Riddick in at middle linebacker he's
gonna be good there I believe you know
Buddha Baker it's safe sure of course
paddy peace still out there
paddy P gotta taste the Tyree kill a
little bit you know first plant
occasions he was a top-five speed guy
first he's still a baller I mean he
really is he took away a slant route on
Tyree kill to start the game and really
in the West Coast offense when l DB
jumps inside you to take away the slant
route the receiver once he takes to one
set to the slant realizes I can't get
inside he has the freedom to stick his
hand up and go I'm running a go around
Patrick guest right Patrick Peterson
jump the slant jump to slant there's
nothing
he's nothing and my home is looking at
him like oh [ __ ] what do I do cuz there
was two slants on this side and now I
don't have anything then to that hand go
up by hill hand went up paddy potted the
ball just to make sure the safety wasn't
over there and he threw a laser and it
was like a 40 yard game first play of
the game
I mean but Pat EP was I know probably
like damn that was perfect and damn I
can't stay with that [ __ ] like that
once he turns up the field and puts his
hand my concern with the Chiefs yeah was
kind of validated here in your notes
where you said Andy Reid is amazing
right now at the window dressing yes but
the scheme maybe isn't that complex it's
not the Shaun McVeigh where you're
getting tons of different variations
it's somewhat of a simple
westcoast Kampf all of the movement
beforehand distracts people right I hope
he can continue to throw a few wrinkles
into the game plan as the season goes on
because this was my fear I know it is I
that by week 11 my Andy Reid's kind of
showing you everything yeah and will the
creation still be coming yeah I would
hope so again it's not gonna be like
Alex Smith the last two years and the
Chiefs they're not gonna fall off but to
your point yes it's not always like Sean
Payton McDaniels McVeigh where I'm just
like whoa I don't even know what that
play is or that was really cool or
whatever it is it is about the window
dressing and then part of his greatness
is evaluating talent and he has talent
on the team to put the pressure on you
that way and that's really what it's
about more than anything it's yeah the
scheme is solid it's good it's sound it
has everything you want but it's not
mind-blowing but he does a great job of
making the same play look different with
certain formations and the window
dressing as you're talking Arif eye what
window dressing means we're dressing
like hey he might run it might be curl
flat right there's 12-yard curl and
somebody in the flat okay they did that
another two receiver set but then the
next time he might run curl fret and go
I'm gonna fake the speed sweep to Tyree
kill and then he's gonna run him to flat
and we're still gonna have the curl and
the defense is like oh gosh it's all
sudden the curls still open so that's
what I mean by window dressing making
the same play look different but it's
really not different he just changed
some pieces and moved a few people
around with motions or whatever else to
get the defense thinking to open up the
same so how do you coach against that on
defense that would be what we saw in
this game like with McDermott or a Steve
looked you've got an understand when
they get in these formations they laces
whether you're out combinations and this
is what they do
don't fall for you know stay true to
your rule just because tyree kill flew
across doesn't mean middle linebacker
you just start running over there you
know we got somebody there that's gonna
do their job to stop that you stay in
your spot and still stay to what I
taught you all week when it's a two
receiver set over here they do this or
it's a three receiver set they do this
and there's not a lot of coaches that
are real good so in the playoffs that's
when you go with what the window
dressing is because the team is senior
film all year where you run the same
thing every time yeah hopefully in the
playoffs you bring
a few things that no one has seen to
screw over are some of those thoughts
right where a tendency breakers get
broken and there's one thing that you'd
like to see from the chief's office
yeah the cheese have a top-three offense
in the NFL you believe they're missing
one one element yeah and what is it the
power run game just like we just talked
about with the Cleveland Browns or the
New Orleans Saints or whoever it is they
need to find ways to be a little more
patient with the power run game they
have a good old line and one of the best
running backs in football and again
for my money it's going to be another
element that you of course have to
defend but it's gonna be another way to
scare defenses with play-action pass and
bring that part of the game to you know
to their offense I felt like they did
try to run it a lot with Kareem hunt the
second half right but was it not in a
power running style it's always spread
it's a lot of inside outside zone it's
you know I don't you say how are you
talking about the personnel in the field
more big people or do you mean the
scheme in which they're running I don't
mind this I mean this a little bit of
both okay when I'm talking about power
I'm talking about I want to see some
pulling guards or everybody doing a
double-team and then one guy slipping up
just mulling plays forward instead of
the zone concept but we're just gonna
we're all gonna go to the side and kind
of block a guy in our area and the
running back we'll find the lane to cut
in no I want true downhill smashmouth
football that's okay to do under the
shotgun but it's gonna force the
offenses hand more if they get in two
and three tight end sets or 21 sets with
the full-back in there and a tight end
and go downhill and then if you start to
win games or deuce have success that way
that's when you're gonna get one-on-one
with Tyree killed or Sammy Watkins and
all of a sudden Andy can go damn
defenses are playing like this when we
getting these power sets let me give
this a little route combination off that
same power set yeah and fake the run and
all of a sudden now you got a 50-yard
gain down the field let's talk with a
team that many people believe is a power
running team but another team that you
think is not running with power enough
Dallas County you watch this game yeah
and there's still an 11 with three wide
receivers and let's admit yeah dak
Prescott we don't need three wide
receivers on the field no the fact that
they're not just running out of power
formations and throwing out of port
power formations seems like you don't
understand why I I don't understand why
first of all the offense is and this is
from the film against the Eagles on
Sunday yes the offenses it's Ordinary I
don't know what other way to say it I
mean that's why they were thinking about
fire in right of Scotland and Scotland
they're not tricking people and then
also when they get an 11 personnel they
rarely motion or shift or do anything
they just line up a tango here we are
this one over here oh great
and you know doc make a throw and
hopefully will protect and so there's
nothing to it anyways to me I think
they're gonna be more of an advantage
when again two tight end sets three
tight end sets downhill guards pulling
you know read option quarterback design
run plays like almost the aspects of
like they should watch Carolina Panthers
on offense that's what they should do
and go that's what we should do
Amari Cooper over here we got a two
tight ends and a fullback to the left
side of the formation we might pull a
guard with Zack Martin and just
absolutely blow your ass off the line of
scrimmage and Z Kelly it's gonna get 15
yards but once you start putting so many
people down the line of scrimmage we are
going to just let Amari Cooper chew you
up on the backside one-on-one to me
those are their greatest strengths I'm
sick of seeing them jack in the shotgun
nobody open or finally somebody is open
and dad can't hit him so if that's not
what you are get away from it play
through your strengths you got 90
million freakin dollars in your own line
and a top five running backs start using
him Hollandsworth had an observation in
the red zone he goes I don't know what
these routes are he goes they just run
and stop yes they're not they're not
running anywhere no you had some of your
notes that I found really interesting
because I don't understand how it works
you said that first thing is Columbo the
new offensive line right for the Cowboys
yeah taking over was definitely a good
thing right you wrote run game has
better design and imagination yeah how
does an offensive line coach impact the
design and imagination yeah I don't know
what an offensive line cutter does sure
I kind of thought the offensive line
coach a select random harder run
because I just assumed that the
offensive coordinator is like and you're
gonna go here and you're gonna go here
right so what is the offensive line
coach's responsibility I'm gonna learn
something yeah yeah the offensive line
coach his responsibility just like we
talked about a McVeigh or a Shannon or
McDaniels gone man they cracked the code
they know the rules of the defense and
they are screwing it over same thing a
Columbo can do in the run game he goes I
know their run fits and this is not real
sound on their part over here there's no
way that is it Russell Douglas it's
number 32 here's no way we can let him
be the cGAP defender and let that fly
there's just no way it is our duty it
Sargent Allen or a Sewell Douglas
exactly right it's little things like
that okay so all right so there's that
right where they ran a little design
cutback run but what is how is Columbo
interacting with the offensive
coordinator like I'm more curious what
the role of an offensive sharing coach
with the coaching staff right well this
is like my New England experience would
be the best way to do this
really with scar Nekia well I mean maybe
the greatest I may be the great that's
right so and then there Josh
josh has can check his ego at the door
and go you [ __ ] or awesome at the run
listen I'm gonna listen to you so I'll
do the pass game and then he's gonna go
to Dante Monday afternoon ago what do
you think like what's your five or six
runs you really like this week and that
is is that based on the defense your
plan without based on the studying of
the film he also knows his personnel and
goes I think we can run these five or
six plays no matter what front they play
that we've seen on film to here and we
really can expose them or have our way
that way and that's based off of a
defense of weakness events a weakness
right what would your dad or their
schematic alysha's they have in certain
formations where you go again like
you're we were just saying you can't do
this it's our job to expose that and
then the other offensive the other
aspect of the offensive line coach like
my question is is are there running
plays for every team in the NFL that no
matter what defense they're playing they
go this is just what we run and you have
to try and stop it yeah yes deputies I
feel like passing is more reliant on
scheme Ryan and kind of coverages stuff
we're running is were setting the tone
and this is what we do everybody has a
few run plays and a few
Pass place where they go we're
comfortable running these plays no
matter who we play against no matter
what defense they are we're good at
these and we're going to do them at some
point and we've practiced them enough
against all the different alignments and
everything that we're schooled up and
we're very sound and comfortable in
doing this even if the defense can look
and go we know exactly what you're doing
your ability to execute in the 2.5
seconds is just better than exactly
right we practice against the bear front
we know against the three-four front we
know against the three you know the
three you know five nine whatever it is
all the different sets yes like my 2005
playoff year when we went to the playoff
assay I just said the playoffs like
snowing in Tampa Cadillac Williams and
company yeah that we ran 96 and 97 power
king of we ran a hundred runs
we ran 96 and 97 power king 75 out of
the 100 runs and it didn't even matter
did not matter just cuz we were we were
magic at it and if it got into a look
that was so [ __ ] up
and I was like okay this is like we
can't do it they have nine guys where
we're trying to run it they know exactly
what you're doing right loading up right
then I had checks where I'd go okay I
gotta get out of this it's not fair to
ask our guys and that's the beauty I
think of playing off the run is when
you've established something and you
impact the defense to overload then you
can slip out and maybe find a more eco
you have to force the hand of the
defense somehow someway that's what a
good offense does they find you to go
we're going to force you to do this so
then I can do a B and C off of it and
that that is all with all great office
so the big thing with Colombo you're
saying with the Cowboys is he's gonna
come in identify weaknesses in the
defense you identify strengths in the
offense right and it's a recommendation
to the OC yeah or hopefully just
literally a conversation to go like I
think these five run plays without
question have to be in the game plan
this week we have an advantage with Zack
Martin on nada
and they keep using their corner in this
formation to stop the C gap run and I'd
like to see if he could tackle Ezekiel
when he gets into that C gap one-on-one
and then Oh buddy keel runs for 25 yards
and like whoa
the Rasul Douglas didn't make the tackle
how much of a team's game playbook is
not in a game plan for a given week like
you're saying these five plays have to
be in the game plan are there forty
other plays where just like we're not
doing that yeah definitely yes there is
exactly right I mean yeah you you
through your startup training camp and
OTAs you know yeah let's say you have 40
run plays total and your offense yeah
you're number is it 40 run play
somewhere between 40 60 whatever depends
on the team a little bit but then you
have all those well yeah on a weekly
basis you'd go okay we got like these
eight or ten or what we go with or these
five or six and maybe we have one little
wrinkle off of one or two of them to go
like to keep them honest whatever it may
be and is that why Ben McAdoo's play
sheet was such a joke yeah because he
had like seven hundred plays and you're
like I don't really like calling for I
think he just had a big sheet with like
20 plays and he just made it look like
seven a bunch of us is like don't forget
don't look like you're thinking of
something here as I look at this big
sheet it is really funny when you think
about the play sheets and then you think
about Bill Belichick who has nothing
except like a three by five card and
he's not reading he's writing he's
writing down don't forget to do this and
also don't have a lot off their their
communication the second quarters I
can't talk to each other right he
doesn't have a big laminated piece of
paper either I was he doesn't have the
big laminated paper he just has like a
little crumpled up piece of printer
paper no he does not he's gonna sit
there and watch the game he's gonna be
able to observe the game and go we need
to do this better and he's gonna get in
the ear of the D&O coordinator every now
and then go I think it's time to call
blah blah blah play yeah or do this here
I mean I do know that watching that
cowboys Eagles game and seeing Columbo
on the sidelines dapping up the
offensive lineman as a former offensive
line being huge and it makes me go back
to a guy like Mike Tyson
all I mean that could like be a head
coach and eat a bunch of men or Mike
Munchak right the offensive lineman that
becomes the coach yeah what does that
bring to a team it just it's it's for
old linemen who are very much analytical
thinkers I think it puts them at ease to
go this guy's been through it
what we're going through and he knows
this isn't easy he's gonna be a fair
judge or of us and he also understands
what's realistic you know my position to
run a play or ask a player to do and
that's where it comes like I had a goal
line coach I'm not gonna name his names
but he'd be like I'm not a big technique
guy I'm just to get her done guy and I
wanted to pick well that ain't gonna get
it done that's what I wanted to stand up
and say every [ __ ] time you said it
like that ain't gonna get it done this
week against the Carolina Panthers no
technique against Julius and Chris
Jenkins I'm sure they'll just we'll just
go out there and make it happen guys oh
damn I just got blindsided again good
thing you just were getting her done
coach one thing I also noticed from this
game yeah you still believe that Zeke
has lost a step I do I'm not backing
down from that I don't care I'll shows
equal if he comes in here to bleacher
her and go you're not as fast as your
one when I saw you run an 80-yard
screens against the Pittsburgh Steelers
to the house he is no longer capable of
breaking 60 and 70 yard runs he is your
40 yard when you see Malcolm Jenkins
catching Zeke it's a red flag for you
that's a red flag
it makes me think he's either been beat
up a whole lot already or he's not
training the proper way in which he was
coming out of the draft those are the
two things my mind always goes to or
you're burning the candle at both ends
too much though I was gonna say to bring
a quote I think it was from Shakespeare
that fast guys get slower and big guys
don't get smaller yeah somebody told me
yeah but you know I you know we see
running backs lose speed over the yes
and I but you're saying it's happening
at someone of an alarming writing just a
little bit more than I would expect in
year three and actually you know you're
- he didn't take a beating right he
missed six games right you know all
those yes just a little bit he's still
really awesome but you know yeah I just
hope he's not losing like we've talked
about before and college they make you
run and they make you train and the NFL
they treat you like a man and if you
don't do the little things to be a
professional in a weekly basis yeah I
don't think his legs look the same as
your one they're not quite as thick to
me his hammies aren't popping like they
used to and you know me I consider
myself a professional man looker you are
I know my my other
question was for the defense the Eagles
lost Ronald Darby and through all your
notes you talked about how undisciplined
the Eagles defense plays every game I'm
just like what the hell so my question
is now that they've lost Darby yeah and
I think Sydney Jones might be back this
week okay but that secondary is a mess
can this Eagles defense make it work
with seven games left and really having
to win five of them I I have serious
questions after watching the film I do
you know you guys have a tough schedule
you know okay out of the the thing that
I guess would encourage me is that you
really only play to great passing
offenses down the stretch Giants right
you know I'm not gonna put the Texans
the Redskins the Cowboys or the Giants
in that conversation yeah the good thing
is their division can't really throw
that so maybe they get away with it that
way what I don't understand I mean hey
yeah there's always a few brain farts
from your defense on a weekly basis in
the secondary that's funny they actually
came out this week and said the Eagles
were like we just have brain farts they
do like Ronald Darby at the end of the
half I know I wrote this in my notes
they're trying to high-low him there's
20 seconds up from the end of the half
there's one Kairos about the low right
there's one guy running a 20 yard out
rather that's gonna catch the ball at
the one-yard line and then there's one
guy two yards down the field
[ __ ] let the two yards down the field
catch the ball don't let them throw to
the ball to the one so the other thing
you got a touchdown before the app yeah
those little things lose you games we
forget about them because context
matters and then we at the end of the
game decide why did carson wentz not
throw exactly right that wasn't the
issue that wasn't the issue or it's 20
to 20 and now Ronald Darby's out of the
game now we're gonna play man-to-man
every play what what
I don't think Jim Schwartz is gonna
survive I would say no at this point
that would be my money I mean he might
survive the year but he's not gonna
survive next year okay Chargers offense
Raiders defense I requested that you
watch this because I watch the game and
went if you take away the Melvin Gordon
70 yard screen Chargers are up 13 to 6
yeah then you factor in the fact that
the Raiders in the first drive of the
game got stopped on fourth and goal on
the 1 so that was
the Swede sweet that he's never called
Josh so on this fourth down to start the
game the Raiders are moving the ball at
will against the chargers and I didn't
realize that on fourth down Jon Gruden
called a speed sweep Sims tells me
yesterday it's the first time that Jon
Gruden is called a speed sweep in his
entire career this is my issue with West
Coast guys this is where John Burton's
not above it it's the you know that like
that's the first time he's ever called
the speed sweep he's admitted it he said
it in the press Comcast yesterday so
that's right I was like but it doesn't
surprise me we were the last team in the
NFL to go to the shotgun in 2007 we
didn't run the shotgun and Tampa Bay
until 2007 you know why you know why
John Gurdon well no cuz Bill Walsh and
Joe Montana didn't in 1988 gotcha right
well that applies only 19 years later
it's like that's my issue when you hear
me complaining about the West Coast
offense sometimes I'm rigid this is what
we do and I need a coach in here to
prove it to me and like what what like
okay you know I'm gonna make this into
another thing that I've learned at work
right if you're working at a place in
which your bosses often use the Freid
this is how we've always done it or this
is how it's done
you need to go and work for someone else
because that is a place like Blockbuster
Video
that won't be around in a long time
right because if you're not adjusting we
have a 32 year old head coach that is
blowing the doors off and is openly
admitting that he's stealing play write
all of the best offensive coordinators
are stealing from high school and
college play books and we are hiring
guys still who go this is how it's
always been done and to your point that
guy you're talking about the 32 year old
genius who is stealing plays the main
point of his offense is what the speed
sweep and the 9 million things he does
off of it and yet Jon Gruden called his
first speed sweep in two decades of
coaching in week 11 on fourth and one
the biggest play and ever write us with
your microphone
no no don't like push them oh yeah it's
coming off right yeah but but the big
point of why I had you watch this game
yeah is I think that Chargers are
capable of winning the Super Bowl mm-hmm
I also think the Chargers are capable of
missing the playoffs because I find them
to be very erratic I often talk about
how I love Phillip Rivers because when a
team's not that good he can
overcompensate and play really well but
sometimes I find him throwing passes
that make no sense and in offense has no
flow that was one thing this week for
sure
sometimes I see Melvin Gordon getting
the ball repetitively and wearing a
defense out and then I go 2 or 3 drives
and I go right
why is Austin Eckler in the game this
much right nothing against Austin Eckler
yeah but this is Melvin frickin Gorder
right I see an offensive line that can
push people but then I see an offensive
line that's not asked to push yeah and I
see a defense that allows big plays yes
every single week right I would not buy
stock in the Chargers right now yeah I
think they're really good they're a
great team if you want to throw some
money on them as like a super like long
shot but I do not think that I would
trust them after watching the film do
you trust the charge I trust them I
think there are a playoff team they're
gonna make I mean yes but no do I trust
them totally yet no I I don't yet I
don't think I'm gonna sit here and hang
my hat on their defense to go it's
special and if the game gets really ugly
that their defense can keep them in a
game for some of the better offenses in
the AFC or football no I got to see some
of that before I hang my hat on that now
offensively to get to what you're saying
is you know Phillip Rivers he definitely
had plays of being too greedy I think
they're a whole team did exactly what
Atlanta did to Cleveland except except
came in thinking we got this this is
Oakland we're good we're six and two or
five and two whatever we don't really
have to play our game to win this to win
today that you know the difference
between them in Atlanta is there a
little better than Atlanta and they have
a little bit better coaching on both
sides of the ball that got them over the
hump and I think in my notes at one
point I wrote like it's hard to be
motivated when you're playing your
b-minus or C plus game and you're upset
two three right you know it's just it's
human emotion and yet the Raiders we're
still putting together dry yeah the end
of the game with Cherica Crichton for
forty yards from like if the Raiders
like they went front on fourth down
inside the twenty they didn't convert a
like if the Raiders score touchdowns
here the Chargers can lose this game
different game no doubt you say in your
notes that the Chargers are one of the
few teams the NFL that goes for broke
almost two months yes they're looking to
go deep on every single play they don't
have enough short passing game and
that's why I feel like I watch the
Chargers and they're constantly in third
and eight yes
constantly in 39 because you're pointing
right off the bat that's really throwing
deep yeah they are it's way too
aggressive and he gets too aggressive at
times he looks for it really does where
I just want to go man you know you threw
a post down in the middle of the double
coverage and you know the under route
was wide open first and guaranteed seven
yards and really if he catches it make
one guy miss he's gonna get 20 but he's
always looking for the Dyer which is
great and refreshing but I do think
again to survive some of the better
teams in football let's not measure them
against the Raiders like you're saying
who are one of the worst teams of
football they need to find some more
easy you know just [ __ ] completions
and not always depend on we got to have
perfect pass protection and Phillips got
to make a big throw down the field you
know they need to steal some New England
New Orleans stuff we're okay it's yeah
yeah I threw the ball four feet right in
front of me but now it's second and four
and they don't have enough of that on
that screen though it is very
interesting what you wrote here you go
let's think of situational football
there's 13 minutes left in the third
quarter you're down ten to three yes and
you're in this game why are the Raiders
all out blitzing it was the perfect time
to call a screen but why are defensive
coordinators you're in the game your
defense has been playing great why are
you feeling the need to do this right
now
right all-out blitz and they're all
Gunners trying to show that the defense
I can make big plays tonight they're on
their own what is it with 35 34 yard
line yeah like well your defense is
playing good you're hanging in there why
give
the most explosive offenses and most
experienced quarterbacks in all of
football the chance to go oh they're
bringing the all-out blitz I got one on
ones or this or that and I'm gonna hang
in there and throw a 50-yarder or the
screen or whatever it may be
yeah and again context matters that's
like this [ __ ] that makes you lose a
football game right there no but you
still look at it everybody's gonna go
off
they threw a great screen there and I'm
gonna go now that was one of the dumbest
defensive calls of the week right there
the Raiders need to figure the line okay
speaking of beatdowns Saints Bengals
we're about 15 minutes away from Phil
you said this before the show yeah the
slowest ass beating that you've ever
seen yes yes I remember watching the
game and the first drive for the Saints
right 15 plays eight and a half minutes
Michael Thomas side of the end zone
right half the quarter is gone more than
half the quarter is gone and the Bengals
were just demoralized but what do you
mean slowest ass beating you've ever
seen like okay there was an ass beating
they put on the Buffalo Bills last year
remember where they ran for like 300
yards borrow 50 yards right on Ingram 60
yards right it was just one gash every
in the this it was like it was just 15
yards 20 yards 60 yard like you're
saying this was like four yards six
yards three yards four yards we got him
in third and six right Michael Thomas
seven yards went exactly right it was
just execution and just we're not gonna
be too cute we're just better than you
and we're gonna maul you
honest play-by-play basis and that's
what they did are the Bengals playing
with any inspired play anymore no
they're not their defense is a beat-down
dog I was gonna say like the Raiders and
Bengals are two teams I look at and go I
don't know how much more inspired these
teams are to play the rest yeah III
would agree with that I mean the fact
that the Bengals stole of a fighting
chance I mean they're the number 16 and
the AFC insane right now and I'm rooting
for them not to be like I'm not even
it's like they're gonna get the six I
sure hope that would be the team right
now that I think is going to get the six
I don't mean to be anybody mean to
anybody in Cincinnati I just don't want
to watch them in the playoffs I don't
have more confidence and Titans or
Ravens to get that six
James Ravens are Colts hmm I would
actually because I feel like that's the
three in my mind that I think I get this
thing I think you're right I mean I
would probably go Titans and Colts over
I'd go Ravens right now
I really would I'm scared of the Ravens
still I don't know what to say about
them so you'd say Titans or Colts yeah I
think the Titans are the team I think so
too
I would agree with you I think they were
third good tough playoff match it like
we saw last year in Kansas City yeah I
don't really want to break this game
down too much because I feel like it was
blatant right but I want to have the
breeze mahomes conversation really oh
yeah okay so someone did reach out and
say you guys always talk about how Brees
got so many of his yards from dump offs
and screens and especially in this game
right Ingram screen a Kimura screen all
that stuff but when the Holmes does the
same thing yeah he does screens and you
guys still say he's great right
if you could explain why those two
things are different okay so first thing
is every player needs some help in place
and I'm Andy Reed certainly gives patch
of my home some easy place to so just
take that you know with a grain of salt
there - I'm not trying to say that
Patrick mahomes is just making every
frickin throw in the world and doing all
this and all that a whole like hunt on a
screen oh yeah Hill on a seed sweet jump
ball again I will stand by my statement
that there's only one guy I've seen in
my lifetime that can go I'm gonna [ __ ]
offense and I'll look awesome every week
and that's number 12 in Green Bay
there's nobody else he doesn't get any
of that crap I mean we're all blown away
we're like damn they ran the ball two
weeks in a row in Green Bay that's what
we talk about like and when they do run
like a speed suite with Randall Cobb
right loses to you right right and I
mean we see Aaron Jones go up the middle
were like I think our run game this week
this is amazing I don't remember the
last time watching a Packers game I saw
a motion into a bunch for me no they
don't do anything again it's West Coast
bullcrap sorry so here it is
baltar awesome okay don't get me wrong
the first thing is is this and I hope I
explained I know I explained this to
Josh I try to keep me on track so I can
make all the right points again this
would be the big thing mahomes the
offense is what it is what you're seeing
right now because of mahomes the easy
completions you see him get a lot of
times like the shallow crosses to
Sammy Watkins who runs it is because the
defenses have to play defenses where
they go holy [ __ ] we got to worry about
his 60 yard laser beams down the field
to Tyree kill and he's like one of only
two or three quarterbacks and football
that can make these throws also they are
allowed to call plays that you couldn't
call for Drew Brees because of mahomes
talent they have plays dialed up in
their offense and a more consistent
basis because they go argh I can make
these throws with ease and New Orleans
is only gonna do them from time to time
when they really feel like oh we have a
matchup or we have a defensive scheme
next week that's that's exploited that
way so again I would say that mahomes is
talent is what's opening up so much for
the Kansas City Chiefs and of course
Tyree kill and that factor of his speed
and all that but really at the end of
the day what's scaring defense is more
than anything or Emma Holmes his arm and
then mahomes scrambling and then buying
time and then his arm again so that's
forcing that he is the factor in which
is forcing the defense at hand when I
talk about the Saints offense again
saying this again Drew Brees is awesome
okay everybody he's the eighth best
quarterback of all time
exactly right he's amazing but he is not
the cog okay that is making this offense
go he is not the number one thing I
would argue to you that the o-line
and the running back play and Sean
Payton play design are what makes it
special
I really couldn't go back into the game
last week and a 5114 victory and really
show you one special throw other than
maybe the Michael Thomas like diving in
the front corner of the end zone if you
guys remember that play it was great
coverage Brees put it in the right spot
everything else slant over the middle
wide open slant over the middle by
Kamara wide open you know Michael Thomas
before the half for verticals running
the bender in between wide open Mark
Ingram you know scream pass trots into
the end zone untouched for 40 yards all
those things so that is the difference
they both get cheap completions they're
both awesome but I'm just saying that
the the dick the the how the offense is
dictated in Kansas City is truly
through mahomes and to give everybody a
little more context to that this is the
bet one of the best offenses in football
for two years running
Kansas City Alex Smith through four
twenty five touchdown passes last year
mahomes is at 31 and were in week ten
okay so that tells you the greatness of
what he is bringing to the offense when
people watch film of the Kansas City
Chiefs and Bill Belichick watches the
kitchen he goes oh my gosh we have to
stop 15 we have to make him
uncomfortable when Belichick was playing
New Orleans he'd go man
Sean Payton does a whole lot of stuff we
got to really get our game plan right
here because he can trick us with some
stuff here and there and that's also my
argument with with him Michael Thomas
you know I think Michael Thomas is
really good I know I said he wasn't a
top-10 maybe he is a top 10 I'm just
it's a it's debatable to me and you know
there was a few instances in this game
where you know what was his name
told the safety Clayton for gentlemen
for gentlemen I don't know all I know is
he's not good enough to know his name
yet and the Bengals thought they could
put him man-to-man on Michael Thomas a
few times okay
now Michael Thomas is really good but
what I'm just trying to say is the
offense and the scheme get him open more
times than not I could promise you that
for gentlemen or whatever his name is
would not be man to man an Antonio Brown
or Odell Beckham jr. or Julio Jones the
defensive coaches looked at the game
plan that week and said we think we can
get away with you covering him
man-to-man a few times and he's close
he's not like it's a great throw and
Thomas is big and he makes the catch but
he doesn't like burn them blow them away
but then there's you know Odell Beckham
jr. who's running against akela
Witherspoon in the 49ers game to the
knight who's like a 4/3 guy or a low for
4 guy and they're going and he's just
blowing by that guy wide open so again I
know I sound like I'm a hater on the
Saints I'm not I'm just trying to keep
everybody the what their offense is all
about one more time I explained that ok
you explained it perfect ok Drew Brees
is awesome the eighth best quarterback
in the history of football history the
NFL exactly right and they're gonna
they're the lead they're the lead
leaders to win the suit
ball and I picked them to win the Super
Bowl and it's probably the third best
trio in all of sport of the sport right
now right I think we'd give the tree to
the Kansas City and the Rams is one and
two as far as quarterback yeah they're
running back and the receiver and I
would go the Saints or number three but
that doesn't mean all three or top five
at their position that's all I'm saying
one question I have was work eleven Bell
Terron Armstead is out three to four
weeks with a peck injury mmm how big of
a deal is that for the say it's not huge
I because German German Bushrod he does
a good job he saw often is he playing in
the finish he's been in here and there
throughout the throughout the season
when little mix-and-match places when
Pete was out he got in the lineup so
they'll be okay okay yeah he's right
he's a good player all right Le'Veon
Bell officially didn't report which is
he's sitting out for the entire year if
you want to watch Simpson left go the
show go to youtube we talked a little
bit about it also online mainly saying
we love the fact that he sat out ten you
wish that he played the last part yeah
main reasons are look at all the guys
that play in the playoffs in the Super
Bowl and raise their value yeah look at
Vinny curry and beau Allen last year for
the Eagles look at Ray Burton they can
go on and if you perform big you get to
move on I have though my landing spots
for Le'Veon Bell and I'm gonna run them
by Simms and I want you to know I want
to know your opinion on them your take
and if you think I'm right okay cool I
have it down to a top six okay I have
two teams that I think make a lot of
sense yeah but I don't know if they have
enough money for him okay my number 16
the Baltimore Ravens sure do not have a
running game still looking for running
backs they only have 35 million dollars
in cap space right now but Lamar Jackson
and Le'Veon Bell would be a hell of a
combination and he gets to play the
Steelers twice every year right and
after what he's going through right now
there's some motivation my number five
yeah the Miami Dolphins right 20 million
dollars in cap space to benefits one we
know he loves Miami to no state tax in
Miami we know how much he loves money my
problem there is what are the Dolphins
does levian really want to go there and
I don't think they have
enough money to make it happen my number
four team the team that I think a lot of
people have never number one I just did
number 500 you're going back way
holy-moly numbers are tough for my man
Sims number for a team that is
definitely the favorite the New York
Jets sure the New York Jets 106 million
dollars
Le'Veon wants to be more known you come
to the Jets my problem there is though
the offensive line doesn't look right
it's an organization that can they
really invest that much money in a levy
on bail they have a lot of other holes
to fix with contracts like Tremaine
Johnson all over the that's the best one
yet I think daddy your first three that
you've said I look at that one going
that would be the leader of the first
three keep going number three the Jets
are the betting favorites about a lot
yes number three the Indianapolis Colts
123 million dollars in cap space most in
the NFL if you're Le'Veon Bell you're
going man I get to play indoors eight
times
I got Andrew Luck and T Y Hilton to
stretch the field right I have an
incredible incredible offensive line
right that's all like under the age of
26 only knocked there they gotta be
looking at Marlin Mac and going we got
some good pieces yeah right right only
thing though is Marla Mack plays then he
doesn't play yeah any plays but Chris
Ballard will he take a risk on a guy
like levy on I'd love to see him in
Indianapolis I think it would be great
Frank Reich knows how to use that
position too but what's more likely out
of you the jet to the Colts that's my
for my three surprising for me right now
out of those if I were loving a bell I
would go I'm going to the Colts okay
yeah of those two GM's whose mogul it
most likely to pay top dollar for him
probably make Agnon for the Jets okay my
number 242 million dollars the Green Bay
Packers Aaron Rodgers Le'Veon Bell I
think this would be I think this is
maybe just me rooting for something I
don't think it's crazy but I also think
that he's played for the Steelers he
goes for the Packers and I think the
Packers are going we need to give him a
weapon right we can kind of get two
positions for one here since we're kind
of cheap and levian goes I play for the
Packers and the Steelers right it's
historic and gutten goosed I think
you're right Brian right he is publicly
stated that there
gonna be more of players in free agency
so that wouldn't be crazy my number one
team number one obviously I wonder who
you're gonna go with I'm gonna give you
three seconds I'm just see the Eagles of
the Raiders it's neither of my number
one team it's a state in which again no
state tax it's a team again that's got
weapons all over the field and you might
like Lamar Miller but you're not gonna
like him as much as levy on bail the
Houston Texans to Shaun Watson levy on
bail DeAndre Hopkins Demaryius Thomas I
think an Lamar Miller and Lamar Miller
I think Le'Veon Bell on the Houston
Texans is the ultimate dynamic situation
for him and again he saves money it's in
Houston I don't know I love them the
most they're the team that gets me the
most excited I mean I hear you loving
them the most uh yeah I mean again I
think it sounds like you think the Jets
are the most likely to sign I I do feel
like the Jets are looking for that type
of player exactly right big name splash
Jackie it's good for the organization
look we got levee on in sake one in the
same city and you know I'll say this too
you know of course one would get you the
most excited of the ones I name-o I mean
it's Pitou you sit in Green Bay for me
or the Colts all three of those are my
really face I think we can be really
successful it'll make their teams better
it'll be fun to watch um and you know to
the levian thing too I'll say this of
course I want him to play I wanted to
watch him and and maybe I'm wrong about
the value what are you saying you know
what maybe I'm wrong about the value
thing I said yesterday though about a
creasing your value I mean I he could
increase his value if he played but I
also would say that's a lot of risk to
increase that value okay with I'm not
playing yeah I get it
I me too and I guess the other thing I
would look at it and go I gotta think
that he already knows somebody's gonna
pay him close to what he wanted things I
do I mean that's the way agents work
what's what agents do agents have all
the inventory so the so they got all the
the grocery goods and the supermarket
calls them to go hey you got the goods
we'd like to talk to you because we need
those goods we need some cereal we're a
little low in
I'll number four where the cereal is and
that's what they have and I would think
part of the decision of him finally
going I'm not playing
was the fact that there's a team out
there that's going you're number one on
our rate is that allowed
for team no no I mean it's not but
there's nothing you can do to stop that
it goes on all the time
in every industry I know ya know every
boundary you say hey we're not gonna
fill this hole right eight months and
then I want you to be my link Texas
right the GM talks to the agent about
somebody else that is on his team and
then you know the GM goes hey what are
some school of you on here I would think
that he already has a good inkling of
where he's going to go I would think so
we read Chris Simms bet Le'Veon goes
next year if put on the spot on a random
Wednesday podcast in the middle of
November Chris Indianapolis Colts put it
on Twitter Andrew Luck Le'Veon Bell with
Marlin Mac and I he hides behind him and
Quentin Nelson Quinton Nelson and that
young offensive line with T Y Hilton
stretching it with a double tight end
set with Jack Doyle and Eric Ebron they
still will have a ton of money to go out
and get another number to wide receiver
are the Colts your Superbowl pick next
season thank you not yet but yeah I
think that would be amazing I think the
big question would be how do they value
Marlon Mac and are they willing to spend
that money for that position which you
know some GM's are just like I refuse to
there's other guys out there that are
awesome that are Kareem hunts who I
should look up Chris Ballard's history
of paying for running backs because I
have a feeling that he'd rather go find
them probably yes I mean it certainly
seems that way in Kansas City I just
know that with a Frank Reich offense
that loves to have heavy sets on there
if if your offense is Andrew Luck under
center yeah the offensive line that's
six double tight ends Doyle and Ebron
that's now 8t why Hilton out wide that's
now nine if you have levee on and maybe
one one otherwise receiver or a fullback
god forbid yeah I mean you could do so
many things I know
no it's a Matt it's a matchup nightmare
I really would love to see that I guess
have you made me bet money about where
he'd go though and you suggest I do I
think the New York thing and I think the
Jets they're gonna fire Todd Bowles
and this will be a good look for the
front office they wanted to get Cleo
Mack okay here's another big name we've
added to the fall we're gonna help out
our rookie quarterback
let us call big phillium big phil simms
man I saw him on television on Monday
night battling the Niners that was a
great game 1986 late November they were
down 17 nothing in the first half to Joe
Montana Jerry Rice they came out whooped
that ass you think Phil knows how viral
he went on Sunday
I'm sure Biscay I want you to ask mister
will you say hello I am mister Internet
these days could this really be you to
calling me on time yeah you know you're
you're growing up you're becoming
responsible citizens of the world you're
paying taxes and you're living up to
your word on time it's it's an important
thing keeping your schedules fill as we
get older and become responsible adults
look at you the internet savant going
viral ain't that right Josh Phil do you
know how viral you went on Sunday for
your true Biscay video no I did not know
oh you went big explain it to him Josh
so Phil you uh you talked with Adam
Cheyne about Mitchell true Biscay on
Sunday and I think you said that you
were expecting the Bears to go 60 nano
this year so you're not all that
impressed with your Brisky CBS Sports
put that video out we retweeted the
video and all of a sudden we've got
hundreds of thousands of people watching
you talk about Mitchell true Biscay I
love it everybody what do they want from
him I did you know that I think I said
to the bear fans what do you want 16 you
know you've been dying for a quarter
yeah I just saw I always say that about
yeah I just thought they would be
undefeated because that's what I thought
yeah you know some my sarcasm is that's
what I love about that part of the show
Christopher knows that it's wild like I
get five minutes just to what's the word
for it
T
just said things that bother me that I
hear all the time and just go oh over
reaction one game defines your career
all that other stuff it drives me crazy
but does it does you know what the the
one thing to that I think people miss in
that conversation he's getting he's
getting compared to Watson in my homes
I think that's adding to the heat I
don't know you know what I hear you son
and I saw you
I think talked about it this morning on
TV right but I don't know if it's sad as
much as it's just there's a group of
people that have a narrative against him
or whatever and I'd almost say against
him but I just keep go what do we want I
have a theory what else you want to see
he's not mobile he's really mobile right
one thing when I remember him coming out
I thought he did a really good job at
North Carolina like you know all these
things he could look and find the next
receiver and then I said man he could
really move and run and I think
potentially he has a very strong arm I
mean he throws a lot of footballs that
are not perfect spirals that still cut
through the wind and the weather and why
45 yards down the field like it's
nothing
yeah so the one thing about NFL
quarterbacks and I see very very few in
their career and you guys you tell me if
you that don't get better as they go
along
throwing it because they learned what
handle it how to do it because they know
accuracy is the thing of course a huge
thing to be successful but they get more
accurate with the football as time goes
along so if if he really learns to
control the ball a little bit more then
men look out I think it can be really
good just case in point I thought when
Kirk Cousins came out I go you know I'm
not sure about it's just his ability to
make those throws that we say decide
game-winning plays and here we are how
many ever years later I'm going man
Kirk Cousins he will throw that damn
ball in the tightest windows he's like
he thinks he's Brett Favre all the time
right and and he gets it in there
and he makes great throws really truly
great throws almost every single week
but what's gonna happen when they don't
win the Super Bowl well you know last
year they did better with Case Keenum
and somebody will bring up his
quarterback raising or something stupid
like that and you know goal gets because
right because they're haters yeah that
is it for sure haters they nobody can
ever admit they're wrong about something
I mean hell there's people on TV well
you know Tim Tebow beat the Steelers in
a playoff game
alright the Steelers were missing like
14 defensive players right you know
whatever was so getting this won't let
any facts ever get in the way and it's
great Tim Tebow did wonderful for what
he did and and I understand all that but
let's let's go to think that it was
going to be a week in and week out
successful game or career that way no it
doesn't work that way no it doesn't what
else do you want to start off about big
guy I don't know out of energy there I'm
gonna hear from my man Adam what is what
is his thing what are you uh well right
bit about well I actually have a
question for you and it's a little bit
awkward but I don't think there's anyone
better to ask about the Giants than you
my question for you is the perfect if
you were running the Giants right now I
think I'm gonna put you don't have to
say this I'm going to say this let's say
this is the last year of Eli is option
one signing a guy like Teddy Bridgewater
option two is getting a guy in the draft
how would you navigate this right now
because the pieces around that position
are great and it's gonna be a little bit
awkward just because it's a it's a lie
and he's gonna be in the Ring of Honor
and all that how do you navigate this
right well you know listen there's a lot
to that and I don't know where to go
I'll say this you know the Giants are
gonna win a few more games this year and
and and look at it look when you see say
Kwan Berkeley and Odell Beckham jr. I
don't know I design a game plan and then
they would be first in everything and
arrest you guys it becomes your way good
luck man
we'll get the ball of these two and I
would be I would put time and effort and
have a lot of heads in there trying to
be creative in ways to get the football
in their hands and so they want a few
games and do whatever I'm not sure this
will be Eli's last year really no I'm
not I'm not just but yeah and this is
it's a change for me just because the
team is going to get better as a year I
think the rest of this year they'll play
better they finally got some things
straightened out I the offensive line I
know it's San Francisco but San
Francisco's defensive front you know
they're not a bunch of wallflowers I
mean they're not right okay so you got
that and the draft the quarterback draft
is falling apart and it really is I mean
yes it's some of these guys we're just
wondering where they're gonna go in and
and how high if the Giants are oh we're
gonna change quarterbacks and go drop
one
well okay you you gonna get the first
pick or you got to loop up or what's
gonna happen ain't you they have they
have one good thing going for them as
far as that conversation is concerned
what's that that all the teams that
potentially could be in front of them
have franchise quarterbacks already
right right you go through like Buffalo
they got it the Jets they got it
the Raiders I mean we know Gruden's
psycho in a good way he might do
something crazy I don't know but they
got Derek Carr the 49ers got it the
Cardinals got it the Detroit Lions got
it right so I got he might be the only
ones go it might be the only one that
really needs a quarterback unless a
Jacksonville continues to fall apart or
trades up or something like or maybe
even a Tampa Bay if they continue to
fall apart that's not the worry about
that's right it's so far down the road I
want to go there but I think it'll be
hard to say oh we want this guy and then
go get him yeah because there's going to
be more than one team that's willing to
go get him right and all these teams you
talk about you know it's just there's
just no guarantee that all these teams
look at their guy go we got the guy you
know it's you always things to just can
change we're who knows better than you
guys we got how many weeks left in the
season seven right now
okay well that's two it's two seasons
you know many things are going to change
and if the Giants did decide to make a
change I would think it will definitely
be go find a veteran that can come in
and be successful right right away now
who would that be that there teddy
bridgewater
yeah I didn't know teddy bridgewater was
gonna be completely free when this year
is over
I thought New Orleans tried to sign him
to a deal right kind of keep him there
when this year is over I mean right now
I'm just looking at early freeze and
said it's like Tyrod Taylor Teddy
Bridgewater and Brett Hundley and Trevor
Simeon he's like you got to think of
guys like Joe Flacco who could be
available you also kind of think they're
not gonna bring Joe Flacco in the only
one is if the Denver Broncos did fall
completely apart you know you think
about that genome again is that a
one-year deal basically he's something
with I think it's like a two-year deal
really just two years 32 right well you
know he would be a guy to say but there
could be something worked out there
Patrick knows him I know he liked him
right you know in fact I'm just it's
just rumors but Pat sure murder could
never get over while they didn't like
him in Minnesota yeah all we're doing
this wedding games he's putting up big
numbers to make a big plays but we don't
like him he's not a franchise guy he
doesn't have the look and we can't sell
him and this and the world I don't know
if that said but all right two things
two things I want to just point out the
giant schedule down the stretch they got
the Bucks this week so they certainly
can win that but here the rest of it
just so you know this yeah
Eagles Bears Redskins Titans Colts
Cowboys so that it will be interesting I
mean there there's certainly no gimmies
there may be no gimmies but you know
it's not like they have it's not like
they're playing the Chiefs the Rams and
the Patriots and teams that I know yes
if they're not going to be right in this
type of situation so the Eagles okay you
tell me now yeah I know you're right
okay okay but now the Redskins tell me
their defense is really good so it's
good and I don't it's good it's really
you know they play nice and reg minovsky
he's crazy so that's awesome and they
kind of play with Greg Monette skis
personality and I've been around him a
lot over the years
and I tell Christopher so many stories
he's crazy I mean he was a crazy player
and he's a good coach never miss the
credit he deserves and him and Jay
Gruden together they make a perfect
match they do okay all right we're good
two more things this one putting you on
the spot but I already know you've
already talked about it who's gonna win
the Rams Chiefs game this week of course
now that the game is in LA that does
change me a little and listen that is a
game you could sit there and go point
for point against each other and each
the other GABAA go good point
oh that's another good point and it just
kind of comes down to I think this what
defense and I know Aaron Donald's on the
Rams but still I'm not sure the Chiefs
defense isn't more suited to stop LA
than the other way around I know I don't
have a great feel for that what makes
you say that because Kansas City will do
like I've told you some multiple crazy
stuff that's on obvious Pasi that's why
they have the number two third down
defensive football one team in Saxony
yes and you know what Adam I'd say just
because they go all out I mean but I say
go out all out they just play like we
don't care go ahead and score the damn
touchdown because we're not gonna let
you control the game or slow the game
down or do whatever and it goes to this
theory not a theory which I really
believe and deeply in that your defense
has to match your offense yeah and the
Rams don't do that but don't break
defense when we got an offense that can
score in three plays let's get our
offense those twelve possessions or
whatever that number is in the NFL every
game and don't let somebody go out there
and just wear the clock down so they go
all out they're gonna pressure they're
gonna do whatever it's man-to-man
coverage that almost seems like every
snap I mean I just go Bob Sutton you are
allowed to play zone in the NFL I don't
know if he knows that rule but it's you
can do that but so that that's that just
saying that that's what I like and also
the other thing is - yeah I feel like
teams and it doesn't bear out but there
is a kind of a rhythm to the Rams
offense yeah okay when Jared Goff is
going to his right okay it's going to be
zone it's gonna be a screen back to the
left to Todd Gurley or he's gonna throw
it deep down the field going to his left
somebody across to the field that is
such an unbelievable part of what they
do that you think there's a little
harder form of late there's some towels
in there offense I think there is right
but they got a good offensive line
there's nothing not to like and it'll be
and I'm sure the big spotlight all that
stuff both of these coaches they're
gonna bring it all out you know what I'm
saying we're going to see some all we
think we got it figured out and it'll be
the opposite that's going to be pretty
cool to watch - yeah definitely
all right big [ __ ] you're the man well
that's what do you want do you want to
give us some history about like nine and
one ten and one matchups is just kind of
popped in my head cuz you were involved
in one when you got in that fight with
Ronnie Lott after the game remember
that's such a bad player you are so mean
well I put fear at everybody's heart
when they think they got to fight me
done' but what was that like playing
playing in that build up where you guys
were both considered the two best teams
in football you saw many games where I
would have great days throwing the ball
against that 49 our defense we knew it
well and all that but that night the
emotions were so high that it was going
to be a defensive game I could tell
almost right from the start going wow
it's different and even Joe Montana
found out it was different you know it
was tough for them they scored one
touchdown he got in there and I'm gonna
kick the field goal but that's just me
to make it seven six and put the you
know put the pressure back on San
Francisco's office but we went forward
on fourth down and missed it I tried to
throw one of those fired over the corner
corners head before he turns around I
forgot who the corner was right but man
I think he played against us too much
and he turned and caught saw the ball
and knocked it down before it got to
line a manual but the build-up was
whatever it is but I just don't entity
in the emotion which how many times a
year do you think
you get that from a football team what
would you say Adam how many times can
you emotionally be at a level that you
are gonna display almost outside or
above your capabilities
I would probably my guess would be like
a quarter so like four of the 16 guys
did that that would be max I would say
fours max we I kind of talked about this
yesterday on Showtime a little that 4 is
the number if you can get 4 I usually
say maybe 3 right well that will see
that this week where did we see it this
past weekend very evident there was one
game and Christopher you should know
this right off the top of your head real
quick well the team emotionally was at a
level that I don't know if they can
match the rest of the year except maybe
for the playoffs let him pull up the
team in Tennessee Titans Tennessee
Titans God I mean man they were playing
right they were playing outside their
bodies Cleveland Browns Cleveland Browns
yes they had great emotion and all that
so that that'll be you know that'll be
interesting to see but that'll but this
game will be fast-paced and crazy at
first just because the emotions involved
and everybody thinking what it's good
turn out to be there was one other
question I wanted to ask you guys I just
forgot Phil I'll leave you with this me
gloating about being accurate I forget
this because I I'm watching
Jacksonville's offense so I'm deep into
it right now
dump offs and screams Phil dump off and
screams I always keep columns up check
downs screens and scrambles I keep I do
that but now when you say I went viral
it did it went the right way right I was
yeah you know you don't have to go to
the time you could thank bleacher report
for it too because we really made sure
it went viral oh okay thank you
about time you paid me something you
know working for free crap has got to
end you know
sorry big [ __ ] it's all we got what
was your question real quick wasn't a
question I was gonna gloat two weeks ago
I said that every team in the NFL that's
on the Cleveland Browns schedule should
hire Hugh Jackson for a week like we do
with pliers where the week that you're
playing the Cleveland Browns you hire
Hugh Jackson and he tells you everything
you need to know and then you fire when
he goes to
next place and what do you know the
Cincinnati Bengals the week they're
gonna play the Browns hired huge accent
oh my gosh there are so many things like
the Cincinnati Bengals are playing the
Ravens this week by the way we're so but
do we say to that and everyone and we'll
get me in trouble so I'm gonna leave it
at that
all right what you're gonna say is
hiring Hugh Jackson might be a negative
more than upon you too dad seein ya
special assistant to the head coach Hugh
Jackson it's a great title yeah
everyone's just making dwight schroot
jokes the entire time all right let's
get to this fan question from our
superfan Matthew Waxman what's up
Matthew acciden Sims and left go is he
singing are you singing their sins and
live go strongest arm at their peak Oh
Phil Simms I'm gonna ask you this hold
on you you looked at me and you said I
think you throw like 47 yards I think
you said Phil Simms of this peak yeah
what's the furthest he could throw it do
you think well damn I saw big [ __ ] a
1993 quarterback challenge throw it
68 in the rain in Hawaii now we should
have just asked him that but I would
guess who he was around like 71 or to
Krista throat as far as me Chris Sims at
his peak I think seventy six or seven
not saying I could throw it harder than
him though that's a different thing a
little bit Matt Sims mm idlest
it's funny I think Matt could probably
throw it the least farthest out of me
and dad okay but I think he could throw
it the hardest so the question really
was strongest arm at their peak Chris
Matt Phil Matt really yeah no not the
farthest he might not have the long toss
right but the strong run anything from
10 to 50 and you want piss missiles
match your guy Matt can throw it like
you've heard me say and I know but
Matt's not playing in the NFL cuz he's
my brother and he's Phil sim son I don't
know they say you can only think if they
hire him
yeah we're gonna be critical we're gonna
know what goes on behind the closed
doors these are weird people in the in
log but to refuse to talk about him
because you just you're trying to
separate well I mean it's just it's
ridiculous that he never got a chance
really he had all these great
pre-seasons and anybody that ever sees
them in a workout or throws goes damn
you're one of the greatest throwers I've
ever seen and then they go but we're
gonna assign somebody else the number
one thing that happens to me happened
it's somebody and left go when I did the
betting right he goes you do that show
with Sims I go yeah he goes see the one
that played for the Jets right and I go
no and he goes kid should have gotten a
chance no doubt every October I was at a
Jets preseason game right and I'm taking
a piss and I just hear some like they
don't even know who I am this is like a
few years ago and they're like they
really gonna give that kid Matt Sims a
chance yeah that's just the thing I know
it's a shame it's a way for you to admit
that your brother is a stronger arm than
you no not at all I don't think he's
better than me my brother had a stronger
r than me yeah he could Matt is a matt
is like a his his technique in the way
he throws the ball is flawless and you
could put him on the field with Aaron
Rodgers and they could throw the ball
around and you'd go damn which one's
Aaron Rodgers I'm not saying he's better
than era I'm just saying just purely
from the look of the ball the velocity
how hard it spins yeah all those things
my dad and I were more you know for
something we just haven't covered a
little bit or get her done we had great
will be and my dad would say we had
hypocrite we have more hands we had more
of a hand like we could flick it and
throw it different ways like that where
Matt is just a machine it's just like I
mean just all over the place where dad
and I yeah it might not be a perfect
spiral but we threw it on the money in
an awkward position because gosh if we
could just get it done that way
interesting yeah alright so coming up
now an interview with our main man
Stefon Diggs again I would highly
recommend going to the youtubes going to
bleacher report The Sims Olaf go channel
and watching this bad boy hope you guys
enjoy the interview in the meantime for
Sims
peace out homies for offend Rick good
evening everybody and for the lef ko
man we wish you adieu see you guys later
oh go on his name is stephane Diggs and
you could tell by his t-shirt but if
you're listening audio I gotta explain
he is here because of new Old Spice foam
or a foaming body wash that lathers in a
flash I use washcloths
unlike Simms and I load up on that foam
ER and upgrade your shower experience
with Old Spice foam are available at
Target you definitely do not use a wash
no it's not necessary
Stefon Diggs do you use a washcloth Wow
okay the soap cleans you I don't
understand it we want to talk about guys
on this team that are not getting enough
respect yeah
Stefon Diggs you got your respect I
think it took people a little bit too
long but you got it and you got the
contract but Kurt cousins man like I
still feel like I see people question
him and it doesn't make any sense to me
lights out he's a he's a baller if you
ever swatch him in game he makes his
adjustments he makes his reads he gets
the ball out quick and he has a cannon
like you can't sleep I haven't thrown a
ball really really before any given time
so you're sleeping on hibiscus that you
can probably just don't watch yeah well
I want to ask one more thing about
Carson so I'm turning over to you for
like three questions yeah sure you are
no I do I was only sticking up for him
lately especially that's right I mean go
ahead I didn't I was just gonna say just
Kirk right his pregame speeches
beforehand genuine from the heart
because every time he talks I'm locked
in like I just I just stared he's
because he looks like he's supposed to
be doing this I don't know you're such a
Johnny company man that's how you stick
up to the that's how you suck up to the
quarterback right there I think is the
speeches are pretty good the one before
the Sunday night game against the
Vikings I mean it gets the Saints
sounded rehearsed but I don't know but
just sound that one sounded like we're
gonna chapter three of Robert Smith's
book about motivation
no in the haver ii-in in the water no no
definitely not and that's where I mean
well the thing I hate about the Kirk
Cousins conversation right now and I
want you to like why is it do you think
people disrespect him like you come out
and say it was your fault on the pick-6
in the Saints game and people still just
go yeah it's Kurt cousins fault we're
gonna blame him I don't know I think
it's just because people some people I
don't know how you don't like her
because if you've ever met Kirk he's
like super nice like I don't know what
it is I think it might be all risk as
fans I'm not sure but he does a great
job like honestly like I wouldn't I
wouldn't allow I wouldn't be the company
man yes
I'm saying that if he does a great job
and that pig was my fault you know we
love Kirk because we know how hard he
works we know that he lives it he
breathes it and he has better-armed
talent than a lot of people but you also
think that his his hump is
partner-in-crime Adam Thielen is
underrated and for one main reason well
I mean you're awesome and we know that
okay and that's why we're talking to you
and we're always popping you but Adam go
ahead you're welcome no problem but I do
think Adam Thielen maybe now is just
starting to get disrespected but yeah I
do think he gets to disrespected at
times because he's a white wide receiver
and I'll be the first to tell you I'm
one that it has to see multiple games of
evidence on a white wide receiver before
I buy in but I just want to know what
your reasoning is or why he doesn't
quite get the respect he deserves and
it's crazy because one Adam went to the
Pro Bowl last year you know he wrecked a
thousand is something yours but I really
think it's because it's the wide
receiver thing like yeah but people
don't take him as serious and it was a
is so crazy like two years ago
we're in camp and we were in we had a
joint practice with some people with you
know I can't I won't drop names so yeah
as a guy wasn't really respecting Adams
game and Adam went out involved in
practice you're saying in that was like
when he was coming up but I really knew
Adam was special a long time ago and
it's just crazy day I don't know what it
is about why they don't why they don't
this in this case right here he might he
might have a pinch of of other stuff in
them you know I don't know yeah
little cinnamon little white chocolate
when it comes to best wide receiver
duo's in the NFL you guys are easily in
the top and your question was for Stefan
who are they competing with or just who
else what are other duo's you look at
that you have like the ultimate respect
forward that you think are in the class
of you and Thielen you know we put you
on the spot there's DeSean and Mike
Evans there's juju and a B you know
there's there's Hopkins and Demaryius
Thomas Leo and Ridley but I don't think
that Ridley is at your guys level yet I
think I think it's just when you have
two guys that can play off each other I
mean it is definitely a competition I
guess for everybody else but you know
for us like everybody just want to have
success you know as far as like winning
it everybody want to eat type of thing
but I mean everybody's gonna have to
choose you know as father who you want
to take on your team on me I feel like
we got we got some of the best guys to
do it like as far as like Adam I think
Adam is top too you know come on how you
doing how you shake it down I think you
wanted to talk with Susan elite so so
does that mean that you believe that you
two are the best wide receiver do in the
NFL I wouldn't say that I would say
overall you guys are killing it this by
week I'm sure was great how do you as
you get ready for the second half of the
season how does the mentality change now
it's I think it's a credit to the
adversity that we faced early the good
in the bad with the tie and the losses
and we learned we learn from all of the
mistakes that we had and we grew from
what we didn't we didn't fester and
fester owners we didn't hang out haze we
just said we just got to keep moving
forward and it showed with the success
that we've had so getting back our
pieces you know David Koch's bag
thinking back as far they everybody
getting back into flowing things are
kind of coming together we just kind of
got to keep preparing the right wing
going in the right direction if we want
to win it they're going really under the
radar I mean yes extremely under the
radar five three and one kicking but
really kind of hurt yourself in the
Saints game in a lot of ways where you
were controlling the first half and then
you know the turnover happened and all
that but we're rooting for you man just
saw it so you know thank you appreciate
always have a good time talking to you
guys you guys did I send you my sweater
though
Oh we'll get you one we
to get you down to something besides the
Old Spice t-shirt that's the only thing
we ever see you it oh and also looking
at this is in our room you we have this
in our podcast room it is you the
matador on your big play on Marcus
Williams
we love Marcus Williams - it's good
picture though piece man
Stefan brought to us by Old Spice foamer
put some foam on your body and if you're
clean use a washcloth Stefan you're the
man